le port de royan peut se vanter d'avoir
l'une des rares sinon la seule femme
marc elle se nomme sonia borowski elle
est veuve et elle a cinq enfants
mais inutile à royan de chercher madame
goreski vous ne la trouverez pas tout le
monde ici la connaît sous le nom de
seugne sonia n'est pas un marin comme
les autres tout d'abord son bateau lui
appartient mais ce n'est pas elle le
patron elle passera seulement ses
diplômes en fin d'année simplement pour
remplacer mon patron s'il tombe malade
dit elle car elle préfère de très loin
s'occuper du vendeur car sonia et non
seulement marins mais aussi mécanicien
je suis le premier à avoir été
mécanicien parce qu'il ya en seulement
12 ans les femmes n'avaient pas le droit
d'avoir des fonctions de pont et
machines à bord d'un bateau de pêche
alors comment ça s'est fait excuser moi
je viens d'essayer de tourner la loi où
je ne connais pas mon avis qu'ils
sentent assez maligne j'essaie de
tourner la loi et j'ai passé d'abord mon
permis de conduire à explosion en
plaisance et quand j'ai eu en faisant ce
moment là j'ai fait toutes les démarches
possibles imaginables pour obtenir le
droit de travailler à bord de mon bâton
est actuellement raya peu près un an et
un dégrilleur par uc autorise toute
personne remplit les conditions à être
marin pêcheur c'est à dire il n'y a plus
cette clause qui existait avant il
fallait d'asti maritime généralement le
métier de marin est un millier d'hommes
pourquoi avoir choisi ce métier
bon je n'ai pas choisi comme sentir
égale à l'homme qui choisit var et les
circonstances de la vie mais on sait que
c est oublier l'idée
comment réagissent en général et les
marins de royan et des alentours eux
aller au bout au début j'étais assez
sceptique d'un petit peu normal
enfin maintenant j'ai d'excellents
camarades je ne dis pas je peux à tout
le monde c'est assez difficile de faire
autrement
enfin j'ai des bons camarades et ses
principales lui disiez tout à l'heure
qu'à bord de ce bateau vous étiez
mécanicien mais ce que vous faites la
cuisine parce que finalement vous êtes
un jeune femme dans ce bateau je fais
pas la cuisine meilleur les marins
viennent pas spécialement ce que je
prends sa cuisine il pourquoi engager
c'est pas la ferme alors qu'ils le feu
on l'a fait à tour de rôle sauf que
patron ya une chose que l'on ignore
peut-être j'ai créé il ya quelques
années vous avez écrit
ça vous avez la même
un prix je crois et pourquoi avoir cessé
d'écrire ce livre aurait eu un certain
succès pourquoi avoir arrêté
je n'ai pas arrêté de bonne grâce mais
je vais à choisir ou naviguer et faire
un apport d'argent réguliers ou alors me
mettre à écrire et à ce moment là je ne
pouvais pas avoir un apport d'argent
régulier et j'ai grand cinq enfants
survivent élevé sur une demande est de
choisir que feriez vous à vous de
choisir écrire est ce que vous pensez de
refaire un jour oui je pense qu'on va
faire comme bateau sera gagnée quand
serait la petite maison les pires au
chaud et mes enfants y briller j'ai tout
à l'heure que être marin est un métier
d'homme est ce que ce n'est pas trop dur
pour vous pensé quand même plusieurs
jours en plusieurs jours ce qui est dur
c'est le manque de sommeil
m'enfin maintenant avec la mécanisation
on ne demande pas de force physique
c'est surtout la résistance et il paraît
enfin les biologistes ne vise que les
pampres résistance faisant jeu égal
croire parce que ce métier demeure
influent il me plaît oui parce qu'on a
une sensation de liberté
on n'a pas tout ces petits puisque in
rio né à la recette on est à terre quand
on est dans la vie les commérages les
voisins et c'est là ce grand large